people have been harnessing the power of
the wind for thousands of years the
earliest recorded evidence of this can
be seen over a thousand years ago in
Persia but these machines have evolved
from simple devices used to cross grain
and pump water to towering monsters
generating enough electricity to power
entire towns traditional wind turbines
come in many shapes and designs but they
have all given way to a fairly
consistent three blade design today
we're going to answer the question why
do wind turbines have three blades we
can imagine each blade as a wrench
tightening and not if we increase the
length of the wrench we can generate
more torque that's the force that causes
rotation likewise if we add a second
wrench we can apply even more force the
same principle applies to wind turbines
so naturally you may think why not add
as many blades and make them as long as
possible
the biggest wind turbine has a diameter
of 164 meters each blade weighs 33 tons
and each cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars to manufacture so more blades
equals more weight and more cost so
maybe less place is better let's compare
our standard three blade design to its
immediate competitors a two blade
turbine and a four blade turbine let's
assume they have the same blade design
for now we can easily eliminate the four
blade design with a quick cost analysis
each of these blades cost a lot of money
adding a fourth blade provides such a
marginal increase in performance that it
does not justify the additional cost so
it's down to two and three blades a two
bladed design can match the performance
of a three bladed design by increasing
the cord of the blade by 50% which
eliminates the cost advantage so it's
pointless or we can increase the
rotational speed by 22.5%
turbines or two blades will spin faster
in the same wind due to the reduced drag
they experience but spinning faster is a
negative let's explore why a faster
spinning blade will generate more noise
this is what a wind turbine sounds like
up close
yeah people don't like living next to
these things so we need to minimize the
noise they make by minimizing their
speed next we need to worry about
centrifugal force as the blades spin
faster their apparent weight increases
thus the central hub and the blades need
to be stronger to resist the additional
stress again this adds cost this is what
can happen when a wind turbines brakes
fail in strong winds
so a three blade design can generate
more power at slower rotational speed
than a two blade design while being more
cost-efficient than a four bladed option
so the three bladed design is a
Goldilocks choice not too much and not
too little thanks for watching and happy
Earth Day don't forget to subscribe and
see my next video which will explain the
history and physics behind winglets
which are those new curly bits at the
end of wings